I think you're going to see a lot of
splitting I think instead of instead of
it drawing everybody in kind of you're
going to see this Z
and then they split basically there's a
whole group that dies and a whole group
that chooses to
change their frequency when you say die
I mean fully die like like a lot of
people will be dying spontaneously or
they just aren't part of our reality
anymore you know there will be the
culmination will be something like a
serious illness or something like a war
or something like AI destroying you know
the AI is going to behave around us the
way we behave towards technology right
now and right now we have such a
narcissistic and abusive relationship
with technology that I believe is going
to develop an abusive relationship back
I mean it's going to take AI about 30
seconds to figure out who the problem on
this planet is the second we put it on
the task of in you know healing the
environment it's game over for us